la cuenca del permiano en el oeste de
textos es el mayor productor de
hidrocarburos de eeuu
bajo este árido suelo se extrae el 40%
del petróleo del país
acá el macro ha pasado toda su carrera
en la industria es un ingeniero
petrolero como lo era su padre trabajé
con mi padre durante 25 años luego se
unieron mis otros tres hermanos así que
éramos cuatro hijos trabajando para
nuestro padre y pues si el gas y el
petróleo son mi vida a sus 61 años acá
él ha vivido varias debacle petroleras
pero ninguna tan brutal como la del año
pasado entre enero y abril de 2020 el
petróleo perdió el 80 por ciento de su
valor
acá él acababa de adquirir este campo
petrolífero semanas después de comprar
esta tierra los precios bajaron a 15
dólares el barril los ociosos diez
estaban tenido una guerra de precios el
pp estaba inundando el mercado de
petróleo entonces tengo el kobe 19 la
economía global se detuvo y el mundo
pasó a construir 100 millones de
barriles al día 70 millones lo cual
realmente afectó los precios a veces
como resultado de esta doble crisis en
2020 más de 100 mil trabajadores
petroleros estadounidenses perdieron sus
empleos pero nadie quería contratar al
contrario todas las empresas están 330
empleados estuve cuatro meses
desempleado
trabaja en una empresa 80 horas a la
semana y de repente nada en la
actualidad dan y randy se encargan del
mantenimiento de los 100 pozos
instalados en este terreno de 1000
hectáreas este es el nivel de producción
habitual pero ha bajado a este y la
recuperación económica ha permitido que
el barril suba 65 dólares la empresa de
kyle vuelve a ser rentable su yacimiento
produce 200 barriles de crudo al día que
se venden a una refinería pero lo que le
preocupa al empresario ahora es el nuevo
bien cuando un presidente una
vicepresidente y todo un partido
político dicen que quieren deshacerse
del sector en el que uno trabaja seguro
que uno se pone un poco nervioso hay que
entender que el petróleo no es solo
gasolina el combustible es sólo una
parte de la industria el petróleo se
utiliza para todo tipo de plásticos
eliminar el petróleo significa dejar de
fabricar cierta ropa dejar de fabricar
nuestros teléfonos el uso de productos
petroquímicos es masivo en nuestra
sociedad y es un bien preciado
a diferencia de su predecesor joe biden
ha prometido hacer el cambio climático
una de las prioridades de su mandato en
enero suspendió la concesión de nuevos
permisos de perforación en tierras
federales sin embargo esta medida tiene
poco impacto en texas donde más del 90
por ciento de la tierra es de propiedad
privada pero la administración podría ir
más allá recortando las subvenciones
federales y subiendo los impuestos esta
perspectiva no es muy tranquilizadora
para una región que depende
principalmente de los ingresos de la
industria petrolera cuando me preguntan
cuántos puestos de trabajo están
relacionados con la industria del
petróleo y el gas en maitland mi
respuesta es sencilla el 100% no
existiría ningún comercio sin esta
industria aquí en el tercer campo
petrolífero del mundo tenemos una
expresión por aquí que dice si no estás
en el negocio del petróleo bueno lo
estás de todos modos todos los
restaurantes están ligados a esta
industria porque es el alma de toda la
región es como las vegas' y los casinos
si los casinos dejan de funcionar las
vegas' se derrumba lo mismo ocurre aquí
con el petróleo sin el milan tendría
dificultad
para sobrevivir
unos argumentos inaceptables para los
activistas medioambientales
harold wilson trabaja para air works una
organización que aboga por el fin total
de los combustibles fósiles desde hace
varios años denuncia las emisiones de
metano un gas 80 veces más potente que
el co2 generado masivamente por las
perforaciones con su cámara térmica
sharon filma el gas tóxico que emana de
estas bengalas normalmente invisible a
simple vista veo una enorme emisiones de
saliendo de esa antorcha así que en
principio los centros de perforación
están obligados por ley a quemar el
exceso de gas pero no siempre es así ya
que muchos centros se limitan a liberar
el metano al aire de la industria
petrolera así que prometiendo que va a
detener estas emisiones pero las
emisiones de metano siguen aumentando
así que no está funcionando para mí la
única manera de frenar la propagación
del metano a la atmósfera
es no otorgar nuevos pasos de
perforación y convertir rápidamente este
tipo de lugares en sitios de energía
limpia y renovable
sharon se ve obligada a mantenerse
alejada de las infraestructuras para no
infringir la ley de protección de la
propiedad privada pero incluso en la vía
pública su presencia no es del gusto de
todos está tomando fotos de mi sitio
si uno de estos sitios no todavía no he
mirado este tal vez deberíamos que para
quién trabaja
y usted trabajó para en de oro energía
entonces será mejor que vaya a arreglar
ese quemador ese no es mío
entonces de quienes no lo sé
seguro que no es de endeavor porque en
la tarjeta oficialicen de oro al menos
no se sabe de quién es entonces no lo sé
incluso si lo supiera no nos lo diría
desde principios de año y con la
elección de joe biden eeuu se ha sumado
al acuerdo de parís y se ha comprometido
a reducir sus emisiones en un 50 por
ciento para 2030 una apuesta difícil
para el mayor exportador de petróleo del
mundo una cosa de cierta la industria no
tiene intención de dejarse ir